yeah I know you and I had talked a lot
about this it takes a lot of courage for
these women to come forward and I think
that they should continue to do
something that they will continue to
speak up yeah I also want to say this
that this is a moment that demands a
frank and honest assessment about where
we stand and more generally the safety
of women let me be very clear there is
no excuse for this alleged behavior it
is systemic and pervasive and I've been
doing a lot of listening and I'm going
to continue to do that this I know is
true women cannot achieve equality in
the workplace or in society until there
is a reckoning and a taking of
responsibility I'm really proud to work
at CBS News there are so many incredible
people here especially on this show all
of you here this will be investigated
this has to end this behavior is wrong
period I certainly echo that and I I
have to say Nora I really am still
reeling I got an hour and 42 minutes to
sleep last night both my son and my
daughter called me Oprah called me and
said are you okay I am NOT okay after
reading that article in the post it was
deeply disturbing troubling and painful
for me to read that said I think we have
to make this matter to women the women
that it was spoken up the women who have
not spoken up because they were afraid
I'm hoping that now they will take the
step to speak out to that this becomes a
moment of truth you know I've enjoyed a
friendship and a partnership with
Charlie for the past five years I've
held him in such high regard and I'm
really struggling because how do you
what do you say when someone that you
deeply care about has done something
that is so horrible how do you wrap your
brain around that I'm really grappling
with that that said Charlie does not get
a pass here he doesn't get a pass from
anyone in this room we were all deeply
affected we are all rocked by this and I
I want to echo what Nora said I really
applaud the women that speak up despite
the friendship he doesn't get a pass
because I can't stop thinking about the
anguish of the
these women what happened to their
dignity what happened to their bodies
what happened maybe to even their
careers I can't stop thinking about that
in the pain that they're going through I
also find that it's it's you can hold
two ideas in your head at the same time
you can grapple with things and I to be
very honest with you I'm still trying to
process all of this I'm still trying to
sort it out because this is not the man
I know but I'm also clearly on the side
of the women who have been very hurt and
very damaged by this and I'm gonna you
know I haven't spoken to him have you
spoken him I haven't spoken to him I
intend to speak to him certainly later
today when I'm very sorry and I'm very
glad that they have spoken up I said we
are gonna continue to do our reporting
on this story and other allegations that
have come forward and we're gonna
continue I just say this or we have a
great team here and we are all as you
said very committed to bringing you the
news even when it affects us so deeply
none of us ever thought that we'd be
sitting at this table in particular
telling this story but here we are but
we will continue to report the news as
we always have